i now want to re-figure out what this
mystery mass is but we're going to start
using a little bit a little bit more of
mathematics and mathematics really are
just a language of symbols for
representing
ideas for representing relationships
between things and so the first thing i
want you to do is think about if you can
express a relationship mathematically
between this side of the scale and that
side of the scale and i'll give you some
hints we know that they have equal mass
so maybe you can set up some type of
relationship using an equal sign somehow
showing that this right over here is
equal to that and i'll give you a few
seconds to do that
so let's think about a little bit what
do we have on this side well we have our
mystery mass and i'll represent that
mystery mass by the question mark right
over here but that's not the only thing
that we have on the left hand side we
also have these other three kilograms so
let me right over here i'll just add
we'll assume that we're dealing with
kilograms so we have the mystery mass in
kilograms plus three more kilograms
that's what we have here on the left
hand side now what do we have here on
the right hand side well we just have
one two three four
6 7 8 9 10 kilograms so we just have 10
we just have 10 on the right hand side
and what else do we know well we know
that the scale is balanced that the mass
here is equal to the mass here because
the scale is balanced the way it's been
drawn we know that these two things
these two things are equal so we have
just set up an equation we're using
question mark as our unknown we don't
know what this mystery mass is
if we add 3 kilograms to it then we see
that it has the exact same mass as 10
kilograms now my question to you is what
can we do to this equation so that we
can essentially solve for the unknown so
that we can figure out what the unknown
is
well we saw on the last little problem
that we had that if we wanted to figure
out this mystery mass we had to remove
three of these three kilograms from both
sides if we just removed three kilograms
from one side then the scale wouldn't be
balanced anymore and we really wouldn't
be able to say that the mystery mass is
equal to the thing on the right in order
to say they're equal the stuff has to
actually be balanced so in the last in
the last
video we removed three of these we
removed three kilograms from both sides
in order to keep the scale balanced so
mathematically we'll do the exact same
thing over here we will remove three not
from one side if we remove a three from
one side then it wouldn't be equal
anymore we need to remove three from
both sides so we need to remove three we
need to subtract three from both sides
of this equation in order to keep the
scale balanced so on the left hand side
what are we left with well just like
over here we're left with just the
question mark 3 minus 3 is 0. so on the
left hand side we're left with just the
question mark and on the right hand side
on the right hand side we're left with
10 minus 3 which is 7
10 minus 3 which is 7 and we get the
exact same result question mark is equal
to 7 and for dealing with kilograms then
this is seven
kilograms